i heard a rumor that this was better
than the first season
and that year you hit the thumbs up but
no no no that's a dis
that's a dislike okay so the umbrella
academy is back in full force
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that happens
in the series
explaining the ending and giving our
season three predictions
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you turn off now
if you're new to the channel then please
hit that subscribe button and make sure
you drop a thumbs up as we do breakdowns
like this every day
anyway with all out the way welcome to
the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into the umbrella academy season two
okay so the series picks up almost
immediately after the events of the
first entry
and it centers around the family
attempting to avert the apocalypse
the second season is loosely based on
the second graphic novel titled dallas
and it follows the group as they travel
through time to once more stop
armageddon
whilst the umbrella siblings all
traveled at the exact moment on april
1st 2019
they were all dropped off at different
points in time which leads to klaus and
ben
ending up in 1960. alison goes to 1961
luther 62 diego september 63
vanya in october of the same year and
number five a mere month behind her
now what's alarming is that the timeline
has drastically changed because of their
intervention
and thus america is at war with russia
which inevitably leads to them
firing nukes at one another now from the
off the series really grabs your
attention
and seeing the team murder the ruskies
to my way
it instantly reminds you of why you fell
in love with the show in the first place
it's down to number five to stop
doomsday before it happens
and this is where the main thrust of the
plot comes from with elliot a ufo
obsessive that's been studying the time
jumps he tracks down diego who's in a
mental institution
due to trying to prevent the
assassination of jfk now the show ties
in heavily with the real life
conspiracies
that surround this event during the
infamous moment in which the president
was killed
there was actually a woman who later
became known as the babushka lady
that filmed the entire event she was
asked to come forward but never did
and the footage was never found it could
have really shed some light on one of
the biggest mysteries of the past 100
years
and her not coming forward just led to
even more mysteries
we do actually see her footage appear in
the season and learn that it was stolen
which ties in nicely with how the true
history is built upon
there's also the mysterious umbrella man
that was at the scene
and though in real life we never learned
who this actually was
the show reveals that this is in fact
hargreaves the founder of the umbrella
academy
he's involved with the majestic 12 who
if you follow conspiracy theories
i'm sure you'll be well aware of they're
basically the illuminati of the ufo
community
and people believe that they're a secret
committee of scientists military leaders
and government officials that have had
their hand in manipulating world events
they're one of the major groups in the
entry that make you question hog grieves
allegiances but we'll get into that
further in the video
now throughout the first half of the
season five tries to track down the
family and reunite them in stopping the
apocalypse before it happens
vania is living with a family of three
made up of [ __ ]
carl and their son harlan she suffers
from amnesia
unable to remember any of the events
which led to her destroying the planet
vania takes care of harlan who possesses
autism
and she actually saves his life at one
point in the series using her powers to
resurrect him
which passes on her abilities to the boy
luther makes money as an enforcer for
jack ruby
and in real life this was actually the
person that murdered lee harvey oswald
the man apparently responsible for
killing kennedy we actually see him pick
up a gun in the final few minutes of the
season
likely going to either hunt down harvey
oswald or luther himself who's suspected
of the crime
klaus becomes a cult leader and allison
lives as a housewife
helping to advance civil rights with her
husband ray ben
ben also gets some fun too for once now
on the other side of the coin is the
handler who survived being shot by hazel
in the last season
alongside her is of course the temps
commission and their swedish triplet
soldiers
which spend the majority of the season
hunting down the group in order to
remove them from the time stream
in addition to this she uses her
surrogate daughter lila
to pose as an asylum inmate in order to
get close to diego
the two escape the compound together and
we learn about her
being the handler's mole her name was ly
lila
to be fair so yeah kind of gave it away
no but terrible pun now much like
hargreaves in the academy
the handler scooped up the child and
raised her as her own
training her to be a weapon and pretty
much forcing her into a life of duty and
servitude
in order to further the organization's
goals we learned that the handler and
five
actually kill lyla's parents because the
former
wanted to use her as a weapon lila is
one of the 43 children with special
gifts
that was born on the 1st of october 1989
and her abilities are to mimic the
other's powers this is how throughout
the season
she's able to fight like diego whilst
also being able to keep one step ahead
of five
and his teleportation abilities at the
top of the group is their goldfish
leader carmichael
and fans of the comic will know the
character well and
he was pretty much five's boss during
his time with the temps
carmichael possesses a genius level
intellect and because of this
he developed a way to be able to talk in
the comics he's described as having the
strategic
instincts of nathan bedford forest and
this makes him a master at keeping the
timeline intact
now throughout the series there's some
really great moments and from the off
i think this is definitely better than
the first entry in every way
vania accidentally probably starts the
crop circle phenomena
and begins her relationship with [ __ ]
aka the mother of the family that she's
with
klaus visits dave before the two ever
met in the vietnam war
and this kind of plays out to varying
degrees of success
lila 5 and diego infiltrate the mexican
consulate
in order to get hog reefs and the entry
is very very packed
it's at this point that we come across
grace and i love seeing both her and
pogo pop up in the season
even though we know what happens to the
both of them later in their lives
after the midpoint the family meet with
their father and it's one of the best
scenes in the entire series they all go
through their powers with him
and he completely shouts down diego you
really get the idea of the psychological
power that he has over them
and hal greaves is fascinating to watch
i actually think this scene plays
massively into the ending and
considering we never actually get that
many interactions between them as a
family
i really appreciated how this played out
now we learned that hargreaves is
involved in the kennedy assassination
plot
and though he doesn't wish for the
president to be killed it's clear that
he's someone
who will benefit from his death if
you've read the comics then you'll know
that hargreaves is actually an
alien masquerading in human form and
this is revealed at the end of the
season
and i just think it's a brilliant moment
it turns out the reason that the
character actually got involved with a
majestic 12
is because he's interested in gaining
access to the dark side of the moon
so yeah that explains why he's an
olympic gold medalist
inventor athlete youtubing podcaster
that's able to develop
simians to the level pogo is at the
reveal was actually teased
all the way back in season one when we
saw the character comforting his dying
lover
before exiting the property to watch
rockets blasting off into the sky
we learned very little about his origins
in the show and
unfortunately about the same amount in
the comics all that we discover about
where he comes from
is the following passage for reasons are
known so reginald set out with his
bodyguard abjarat
aboard his private vessel the minerva
rumored to be powered by the remains of
king armand courage iv
so yeah very little we know but
hopefully we learn more in the third
season
now with the death of kennedy the
advancements to space travel will be
pushed further
and thus america will beat russia to the
moon and he'll be able to get there
quicker by aligning himself with the
american forces
this moon mission of course was centered
out in the first season with luther
being stationed out there at his
father's behest
the handler also drops information to
the triplets i mean twins
on diego's location and they go after
the group promising to spare number five
they kill elliott and five meets with
the handler at a hideout
and she promises to cancel the
apocalypse in the future
as long as he kills the board so that
she can take over
five travels to 1982 and takes them out
by turning into an axe wielding murderer
that carves up most of them and smashes
carmichael's fish tank in
it's just not cricket but it carries out
the job and then returns to the 60s
they're then given a window to travel
back to the future but they miss this
due to the issues thrown at them this
forces five to interact with his past
self in order to be better prepared for
what's coming down the line
now what holds the group up is an
awesome scene and we get to see allison
bust out a rumor powers whilst
backstreet back thumps away in the
background
diego is kidnapped by lyla and vanya
faces off against the forces sent in by
call
the husband of [ __ ] and their son
harlan this leads to the fbi
interrogating her under the belief that
she's a russian spy
and during this she begins to recall the
events that led to the apocalypse in the
first place
we learn in the timeline that this made
her alicia powers and this
coincidentally happened
just as jfk's motorcade was passing the
fbi headquarters in dallas
jfk survived the event and before
becoming lined up in the crosshairs of
lee harvey oswald's rifle
the convoy sped away because vania blew
up the fbi building
it was thought that the attack was
actually supposed to be that on the
president
in order to send a message to him as
vanya was believed to be a russian
informant
it was assumed that the soviets were
behind it and this is the reason that
the war starts between the two countries
and thus the apocalypse begins her
powers fully manifest
and they connect to holland which freaks
out his father and he tries to take him
to an asylum
[ __ ] holds him at gunpoint and harlan
gets caught in the crossfire of carl
trying to wrestle the weapon away from
her
because he now possesses vonia's powers
the bullet backfires and kills his dad
something that vanier likely wanted to
do to her own father
he watches the family try and prevent
her from bringing forth the end of the
world once more
and ben possesses her in her mind he
discovers the white violin
which in the comic books is the
villainous name that the character goes
under
ben actually confronts her and makes you
realize that it's not her fault what's
happened to the world
and that it was due to the actions of a
family he says that they treated her
badly
but they still love her and that they're
on the outside fighting for her
which is something worth remembering
judah ben actually completing what he's
been hanging around for
which is making sure that the family are
okay he leaves the land of the living
and can finally be at peace which
i'm not crying you're crying this stops
the dark path that vania was supposed to
go on
but diego actually causes more issues
which we'll get into in just a bit
meanwhile we watch as older 5 descends
into paradox psychosis
whilst younger five who looks older
yes it gets confusing strikes a deal up
with luther to off the older five
and then travel to 2019 to stop bonya
ending the world there
at the temps commission the truth about
five killing lila's parents is revealed
and the handler manipulates the
situation dependent on diego
ii due to her being worried that her
daughter will end up becoming closer to
him
angered at call michael's attempt to
reveal the truth she swallows him
and luther and older five send his
younger version through the portal to
2019.
now this closes the paradox loophole and
it allows for most of the first season
to happen
however it also confirms that there's an
alternate timeline
as the five that went back was likely
still in his older body
due to knowing the correct calculations
to travel there's a lot of alternate
possibilities
and timelines going on in the show and
this is an important thing to bear in
mind
as we get into the ending unfortunately
the time briefcase that the younger five
was carrying is destroyed
and thus the group cannot travel back to
the present aware of what they're up to
in regards to attempting to stop the
kennedy assassination
hog greaves instead sends a plant which
diego tracks down
and the president is killed as he was
supposed to be hargreaves however
did not want this to happen and he goes
to the majestic 12
killing them after they threaten to
reveal who he really is
in the final episode we learn that since
the kennedy assassination
they've become the most wanted people in
the world it's at this time that vania
becomes aware of holland freaking out on
sissy's snow-covered form
and the family travel together there
tailed by the last of the triplets
the handler materializes with the entire
temp commission
to take down the academy for what five
did to the board the show devolves into
all our action
with bullets flying towards the group
however vanya wipes out all of them
except for the handler and lila lila's
abilities are revealed and her and five
end up going head to head she tells five
that he murdered her parents
but he retorts the hannah was actually
behind it and that she came on the job
with him
in order to get lyla the family embrace
her as one of their own
but the hannah arrives and shoots them
all with an uzi before being killed by
the last surviving member of the
triplets who discover that she set him
and his brothers up
as he stands over five about to kill him
the character uses the last of his
strength to reverse time to the moment
before the handler arrived
and he stops her from taking them out
she's still killed by the swede though
who decides to leave the group alive
bonya rushes to harlan and absorbs his
power
and thus saves the day herbin his
assistant from the temps commission
arrive
and reveal that he's been elected as the
new head of the board
bonnie goes to [ __ ] to try and take her
and hull into the future
but [ __ ] realizes that they'll always
live in danger if they go
it's heartbreaking to watch but also
bittersweet at the same time
as [ __ ] can now be herself because of
what vania has brought out of her
and they agree to go their separate ways
with her traveling to mexico
whilst holland shows that he still
possesses powers
rey finds a letter from alison detailing
how things will get worse
before they get better dave enlists in
the army
and the final swede takes up klaus's
place as the leader of his cult
jack ruby watches the death of the
president and picks up his gun
and he may end up hunting for luther or
at least getting his offspring too
or he could be going after harvey oswald
but yeah let me know which one of those
that you think
the group take the briefcase and travel
to 2019
one day after the apocalypse originally
happened to see their father is still in
the land of the living
hargreaves states that this is now the
sparrow academy and we see there are
more superpowered children
including ben who's still alive the
sparrow academy is actually the name of
the fourth umbrella academy book
which centers around the other 36
children born on the same day as the
super powered beings
i think that the next season will sort
of combine volume 3 and 4
but you're probably wondering exactly
what has happened
well from the version of five and
meeting his older self
which never actually happened and then
traveling back in time
whilst being in his older body we know
that there can exist
alternate realities and timelines this
is also shown in the opening of the
season
in which we see a version of the
timeline where the apocalypse still
happens
now if i know how greaves let's be
honest i don't but from
what i do know he's very very stubborn
i think that the meeting that he had
with the group wouldn't have happened
originally
however the fact that it did massively
altered things
the man in the babushka ladies footage
was clearly the character
but he sent a body double instead after
learning of the academy's mission
showing that he used the knowledge they
gave him to change future events
thus i think meeting the group like this
and seeing that they were all over the
place would have put him off trying to
adopt them
and therefore he would have picked
others from the 43 children that we know
were born with special abilities
his stubbornness to accept them in any
form is also
shown in the change of the academy's
name as he likely wants to distance
himself
from what come before it's also possible
that because harlan was gifted with
special abilities
all the way back in the 60s that the
timeline itself has changed
and he may have went off the deep end
which forced the academy to be formed
sooner
who knows he may even be a member as we
do see a character
levitating something just like how he
did with the bird
this bird looks a lot like a sparrow and
i don't think it's a coincidence that
it's dropped here and the academy is
called the sparrow academy
he would have likely have been the
world's first superhero and due to his
age it is possible that har greaves
called it the sparrow academy in tribute
to him though there are possibilities
that there could be
i also the more i think about it the
more i realize he is far too old to be
hanging around with these kids
i also think that due to grace in the
past discovering what hargreaves was up
to
and then likely seeing jfk murdered not
long after
that she stepped away from the character
probably taking pogo with her
pogo would be alive in this timeline if
he still was at the academy
due to vania not being there now the
biggest twist in all of this
is that ben is alive and by the looks of
it he's the leader
this is cemented by his picture which
hangs in hargreaves's place
and yeah it's such a good twist ben was
one of the most powerful members of the
family
and with vania not in his timeline it
looks like that he may have actually
taken up that position
thus his death the events that led to it
and more
did not happen likely because they were
probably caused by the academy
ben in the comics was known as the
horror and it looks like the character
has turned to the dark side
and i think for the third season the hog
greaves will have to face off against
this group
in a sort of superhero showdown the
third volume hotel oblivion
actually centers around developing the
greater universe as there becomes an
increasing amount of superpowered
lunatics
running about the planet i think this
will be brought across to the third
season
and rather than ending the apocalypse it
will center on ending superpowered
beings
altogether i actually have a feeling
that holland may be a super villain that
vania may have to reconnect with in
order to stop him and
they'll also have to bring ben back to
the light after revealing what he was
like in that dimension
in the third volume the group fracture
off and do their own things and who
knows
maybe season 3 will pick up far in the
future with them having to deal with
living in a timeline
that isn't their own the first season
dealt with them living apart from one
another
the second season dealt with them living
in the 60s and carving out a life there
and it's likely that the third season
will follow this sort of aesthetic
we're in for a big treat though and
hopefully it isn't too long before we
see them back on our screens
anyway that's our thoughts on the show
and obviously i'd love to hear yours on
the entire season
comment below and let me know and if you
want to check out our review of the show
as a whole
then make sure you watch it after this
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box said
is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on thanks for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you